serena hey um
a lot of people thought a lot of people
were surprised when you left
you said though matt wasn't your person
and you would have done a disservice by
staying
i've thought about it so much and i've
just been like
emotionally torn up over it
[Music]
i'm just disappointed you know that's
not how i saw
our journey ending
what did you mean by that
i think at that point in my journey i
had enough confidence and certainty that
this was not going to be
a forever thing or at least i wasn't
gonna get to that place where i was
confident it would be a forever thing by
the end of that journey
and i felt that staying
knowing where i was at knowing the
doubts i was having
would not be fair to matt because he's
on his journey to find his wife
and the other three women were in that
place
where was your heart and where should it
have been i think at that point we'd
spent enough time together
that i was really hopeful to be feeling
i was either in love with him
or was definitely going to fall in love
with him
and i just wasn't i wasn't i was falling
for him i was falling in love with him
you saw me communicate that and that was
100
honest but that that something
was just missing for me from the
relationship and i don't know if it was
the situation or him and i or
something else but i just i wanted to be
a hundred percent confident
if i was gonna accept an engagement i
wasn't when you went home for that home
visit
what did it were there things that your
family
said to you that weighed into this
decision did
your parents pull you aside and say hey
i don't know if this is the right deal
you know what you guys didn't get to see
was my family
really liked matt like if i had fallen
in love
and had been there and been like this is
my dude and
i'm getting engaged and we're going to
schedule they would have been like great
we really liked it
i think seeing that and i interact it
was obvious that
we had this natural chemistry this
natural connection but when they sat
down to talk to me
i struggled when i was trying to
communicate
where this relationship was going and
where my feelings were and they were
like so you're falling in love but
you're not in love are you gonna get
there
do you love it like do you love him he
on paper and in my head checks
every single box to me it seems like
there's just something missing
they were asking those tough questions
knowing the timeline that i was under
and how
short of a timeline it is and when i
struggled to answer some of those
questions
that's when they pried further and
that's when those doubts kind of started
coming up from my gut now were you
surprised
he cried he was in it how did that how
did you
feel and even when he saw you you could
see in last night's show
it looked like he he still felt
something
how did that make you feel i mean it was
really hard i know that i struggled
a ton making that decision and the days
leading up in the days
after was very emotional about it
so to see that he was also emotional um
made it that much harder you know i care
about him i never wanted to hurt him the
way i did
and it it just made my heart break that
much more about the situation
it was good to see him in person at the
women's hall i was happy that you know
that she had come to that conclusion and
that she was going to be closer to
finding someone that she was compatible
with if it wasn't me but um
it was hard yeah it was really hard for
me too
and i felt being honest with you
was the most respectful thing that i
could do i think that we had an amazing
connection
and we definitely had chemistry and that
doesn't just go away
just because we're not together anymore
so there's obviously still that
connection between us
um but i do hope he's found love and
happiness with someone
who do you think he found love and
happiness with if you look at the last
three women
michelle and rachel which one do you
think he ended up with i mean
okay if i'm going from a viewer
perspective because i'm watching this
unfold just like everyone else yep
the only person we have seen him say
i'm falling for you is rachel
tonight this confirms that i'm i'm
falling for rachel
okay if let's just playing it out if it
is rachel
that is a heck of a um conundrum that he
is
in right now seeing what has happened
since the show was shot
yeah i mean there's been a lot that's
come out and
so much that has unfolded within
bachelor nation
since the show has finished airing um
even since the women tell all aired um
i i'm sure that if they are together
and if he has chosen her at the end of
this that is something
that they'll have to address within
their relationship and they'll have to
have some very honest
and difficult conversation you posted
that i
i stand with rachel lindsey after chris
harrison's comments
where is this lens we're holding up and
was that lens available and were we all
looking through it in 2018
where do you stand on this subject now
i mean i do not condone or support
racism whatsoever i am continuing my
education and doing my best to become
anti-racist as one of the women of color
and one of the women from this past
which is incredibly diverse we were very
proud to stand in unity with rachel
lindsey
watching the interview was extremely
upsetting
and she conducted herself with class
and professionalism having to sit there
and conduct that interview
so yeah i mean i think it's shed a lot
of light on issues in the franchise and
beyond the franchise and i'm just
i think all i can do is hope for change
and
education as part of that change would
you want to become the bachelorette
um you know i can see how this journey
works
and as much as it didn't work out for me
this season that's not to say that i'm
not still looking for love
and open to it and ready for it so
if that opportunity was presented to me
i would
definitely consider it let's say if you
were the bachelorette
would you welcome chris harrison to host
that season
with the bachelorette season being so
soon
um i mean they're filming it very
shortly
very short amount of time um i would
struggle
because the amount of work that needs to
be done
here i feel more time would be needed
um i would need to see
the changes that have been happening in
his life
and the actions that he has taken and
will be continuing to take moving
forward
to feel comfortable welcoming him
into the bachelorette season emmanuel
ultro is going to step in for chris
uh in the next special what do you think
about that casting
i think it's a really good choice i
didn't know much about him prior to him
being cast
and have done a little digging he seems
extremely qualified to be conducting
these very difficult conversations that
i'm hoping will be had at the
after the final rows he seems to be an
incredible advocate i'm glad they chose
a black individual to be sitting down
and discussing
the racism within the franchise with
matt and the other women that will be
present
do you think he should stay if this goes
well
i don't see why not i mean i know
there are people out there that feel
very connected and adamant
about chris harrison um i think that
chris has a lot of work to do
and he has to put in that work and
that's not an overnight thing
that is a long-term process of
education and moving from a state of
ignorance and
if emmanuel does a great job i could see
him being a very good fit
have you had a chance to discuss it with
some of the other ladies
yeah there's been some discussion i mean
we saw each other at the women tell
all and we definitely kept in touch a
lot of us are quite close friends
and we're we're exhausted we're tired
it's been a lot
this season um it feels constant and
never ending
and a lot of disappointment
but we are adamant to continue the fight
and to continue to use our voices to
support rachel lindsay throughout this
as well as the people of color within
this franchise and to continue that
fight against racism
have you had a chance to talk to rachel
um i've spoken to rachel very briefly a
couple times since the season ended
i saw her statement and as well as her
video
that she posted on her platform please
stop saying that i did nothing wrong
that's not true i respect her for
speaking out and taking accountability
for
her actions for you know saying that she
is going to do better
and she's going to do the work and i
respect her for saying
do not defend me because what she did
was wrong and
no one should be defending those racist
actions that have come out
um i am really looking forward to her
continuing that work and i think that
she's got
a great platform to be able to speak out
and educate people on that
and i've seen her do that and i'm
hopeful that she will continue to do
that moving forward
as a woman of color where do you think
the franchise goes from here how do they
what's the next step
that will satisfy both sides of this
argument
i think there's there's so many answers
to that question
um this starts with not
saying we need to stop having like the
first dispatcher the first zap actually
the fact that we're just having the
first
bachelor is an issue in itself and long
overdue
i am appreciative for the movement
towards more diversity this season and i
would love to see that continue on
however i think that changes in regards
to the diversity niche would be included
not only on camera but off camera it
needs to be
kind of within the core of the franchise
and that change again isn't going to be
overnight
but it needs to be constant and we've
been taking a lot of baby steps you know
every couple years
and there needs to be leaps taken on a
regular basis moving forward